- [Soldier] Yeah.
(rocket blasting)
- [Narrator] This is the US-made
Patriot Air Defense System.
Since two were delivered
to Ukraine in April,
it's proving to be an indispensable
tool in Kyiv's arsenal.
That's because the system
is defending Ukraine's ground troops,
cities, and critical infrastructure,
amid a barrage of Russian attacks.
So why does the Patriot have an advantage
over other air defense systems?
Let's break it down.
"At the start of the war,
Ukraine relied on a stockpile
of Soviet-era defense systems.
Those weapons can target
slower-moving aerial targets
such as drones and cruise missiles,
but they've struggled to combat
faster-moving ballistic missiles.
Now, Patriot systems are
helping Ukrainian forces
to intercept those projectiles,"
and that's according to a
Ukrainian Air Defense Commander
interviewed by "The Wall Street Journal."
(speaking in foreign language)
- Narrator] Here's how it works.
Patriot missiles consist
of multiple components.
Three of its main parts sit
on top of truck platforms.
The radar tracks missiles
and other targets.
It can detect aircraft up to 62 miles away
and ballistic missiles
more than 100 miles away.
It sends data to the
engagement control station,
that unit then processes the information
before sending it to
the launching station,
which can carry up to 16 missiles.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Narrator] Military analysts say,
"The system has outperformed
initial expectations in Ukraine."
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Also known as the Kinzhal,
the Kh-47 is one of Russia's
most advanced weapons.
On May 16th, a Patriot detected
six Russian Kinzhal ballistic missiles
at a distance of around 125 miles.
The system launched interceptors
destroying all of them.
Patriots in Ukraine fire at targets
using two different types of interceptors,
PAC-2 and PAC-3.
PAC-2 downs targets through
blast fragmentation,
and PAC-3 uses hit-to-kill
technology instead.
By combining the Patriot with
other air defense systems,
Ukraine is now fending off most
aerial threats against Kyiv.
However, the Patriot does
have some disadvantages.
It's by far the most
expensive single weapon system
that the US has supplied to Ukraine.
Each Patriot system
costs around $1 billion
and takes two years to build.
(missile blasting)
The missiles fired out of the
Patriot are expensive too.
Each PAC-3 costs around $4.1 million.
The high cost per missile
and the relatively small
number of missiles in a battery
means that Patriot operators
cannot shoot at every target.
In addition, the Patriot
requires a lot of manpower.
The systems need as many
as 90 soldiers to operate,
but the control station can
be operated in the field
by as few as three.
Gaining more batteries could help Kyiv
in a number of ways amid
a counter-offensive,
namely, being able to
protect ground troops
from aerial threats as they
push to retake territory.
This summer, the US announced
a new military package
worth up to $500 million.
"The aid will include
ammunition for Patriot systems,"
according to a statement
from the Pentagon.
There are at least two
full Patriot systems
operating in Ukraine.
In July, Germany
announced it would provide
two additional Patriot Missile Launches.
Ukrainian President Vladimir Zelensky
has said, "The country
wants as many as 50."